here's what would happen if the sun was  smaller than earth  a small sun wouldn't be able to create  fusion and would burn out completely our  solar system would lose its only star  and since the sun is the source of  gravity that keeps us all in orbit all  the planets earth included would float  away into space in search of another  anchor that's no happy ending for life  on earth so instead let's increase the  size of earth to be bigger than the sun  is now  earth mass would be at least 333  000 times bigger than it is now a planet  this big would generate enough heat and  pressure in its core to become a star  itself so  of course there would be no life left on  this hot star life could possibly evolve  on other planets or even the moon but in  either of these scenarios life on earth  would have no chance of survival because